this is Startalk so I just did Real Time
with Bill Maher for HBO and if we
finished then we've got a little
after-party here and so just go in and
like crash the party and find Omar and I
warm one of my cosmic ties and as
usually had his like left this leaning
political guest and right it's leaning a
little guess I'm just there just to like
cut through that the hot air that's all
I do and put stuff on the table and sit
back so let's go find go mark
dr. Katz pretty much so on TV you see
him with a suit on I think he's allergic
to Sue's because three seconds later the
man puts on is like the universe is
doing the park I'm not doing time I know
when you say the universe you're talking
about the real universe and that the
hippy universe the people out here it's
all right no no I'm sorry the universe
capital you yeah I got that and karma
can we decide if you're a bunch of ghost
muffins please complete learner and also
another one I'd like to know sadness
everything happens for a reason
no no no I'm I think totally doesn't
happen for a reason everything freaking
random yeah all right I did a bad thing
and then a year later something bad
happened before that's just bad
sometimes
and apparently you're a schmuck and
they're both random right completely
reduce you deuce you leave town and you
stand up that's great I'll be in
Pittsburgh tomorrow tomorrow that's not
going to be useful for this August 16th
worry August 16 I don't know but that's
the day Elvis time is it August 6 I know
orga season why not August 16 because
that's the Emmy Awards cosmos got 12
holiday accommodation on in my house
Passover all right okay I'm signing off
Neil deGrasse Tyson force
[Music]